Allen we were just saying that mark is a
very careful builder of his story that
he takes materiality didn't invent but
puts it together in ways that are
interesting and illuminating and now
suddenly as we come to the end of
chapter 5 and moving to chapters six and
seven to me as a reader and as one has
tried to teach the gospel this is hard
because it seems like it's kind of one
thing after another here's a story
here's another story but that just that
moment where he had a barrow full of
stories he had to get in and said
alright I better get on to this before I
get back to my main plot yeah for a long
time people who study the New Testament
for a living kind of classed mark as
just a collector who like to plop things
in and and we have seen evidence to get
that against that in the first part of
the book but this is one of the places
where they kind of their exhibit a right
because you've got in this next section
in chapters six and eight
you've got to feeding stories within 10
minutes of an orally presented gospel
and so people thought this was clumsy
they thought mark is just throwing in
the kitchen sink and between those two
are these sort of loosely connected or
at least seemingly loosely connected
episode of syrophoenician woman and
healing and the page about cleanliness
yeah and and so this is one of the sort
of case studies or exhibits that that
narrative folks folks who think this is
a story from beginning to middle - and
Roy have to look closely at and and what
I what I would like to sort of start
thinking about together as a way of
doing that is is asking after these two
feeding stories because they bracket
this section and they lie out there as
possible evidence that he is clumsy yeah
and I wonder though if he if Mark snot
clever again here in putting them back
to back we saw early in the first three
chapters that Mark had a synagogue seen
with a man who is has a demon
and synagogue seen with a man with a
withered hand within two chapters of one
another and in the second one he said
again right where is happened right this
time again with the with the bread with
the feedings we have a first episode in
chapter 6 where Jesus feeds 5,000 people
and then we have a second episode in 8
where he where he feeds a similar number
of people yeah and the second one is
prefaced with
again yeah okay so the so the narrative
seems to be wanting to throw our eyes
remember that and silly so the thought
that this is marked not remembering what
he just put in yeah it's kind of
dispelled by the use of that connector
yeah and in the second episode very
oddly having seen Jesus ten minutes ago
right yeah give 5,000 and leftovers yeah
the disciples say whoa what do we what
are we gonna do how we're going to be
this is terrible they're all all you
know we we didn't expect company you
know and and and the question then
becomes is mark just is this just mark
throwing something in or is mark trying
to say something about to decide well we
saw last time that part of what's going
on after the parables and in that
section leading up to this is an
extension to those who are outside to
come in and you mentioned in that
context that we're gonna see a little
bit of a play on whether the disciples
are inside or not exactly and here we
get disciples who have been with Jesus
who watch him what calm a storm yeah who
watch him throw out demons here there
and everywhere who watch even now they
hear about a dead woman watch don't
watch the dead girl get up all kinds of
things that are just beyond he's walked
on water here in this passage and they
they get to all those things including a
feeding ten minutes ago and they asked
how we're going to do this that's got to
be a Markin or a narrative attempt to
characterize the fact that these
disciples weren't quick on the uptake
right that they somehow we're missing
something here and that's going to
become differently important down the
line they're missing something about
and feeding but we're gonna see them
continue to miss this other thing yeah
and and so I think that to start is an
important part of why these two would be
back to here additionally one of the one
of the questions is why these specific
things between why the specific episodes
that happen between the two feet ago
okay I'll go with you says the the
sceptic I'll go with you that these two
are intentionally put as sort of hosts
there and cross-reference but why this
syrophoenician woman I the purity stuff
how does all house all that fit and you
had thought that you told me once about
why the syrophoenician woman in the
context of this breads yeah yeah and I I
just find it I find it not only
interesting but I find it a good
explanation that we hear about bread in
the syrophoenician woman the
syrophoenician Gentile outsider right
who begs Jesus to help her right and
Jesus says I've got to feed the children
for the dog right and then she says even
dog gets the gift to lick the the scraps
yeah bread coming off the table bread
leftover so throughout this section were
we're seeing bread and bringing people
you know through it I like that yeah any
reflection on that as where that picks
up is a man named Austin Ferrer who went
to the Gospel of Mark finding numerology
is the food everything you always want
to know how many there was of anything
and then he had some deeply mystical
meaning and and he managed to make the
Gospel of Mark more puzzling than it was
before I got a hold of it which is a
real gift because like another people
Austin got ahold of it but what what
he's always persuaded me of is at the
end of the second feeding he asks how
many baskets that were in each case
Jesus says to the disciples don't you
understand how many baskets after the
first meeting answer is 12 how many
baskets after the second feeding answer
is seven and Ferrer goes through an
elaborate but in on the page of these
kind of persuasive argument that the
twelve is symbolic of the 12 tribes of
Israel and the first feeding of the
5,000 shows that in Jesus Christ God
Israel but the second is symbolic of the
perfect number in a Gentile world the
seven baskets are the leftovers for the
Gentiles and that bark is saying that
this God represented in Jesus Christ
feeds the hunger of the Jews first
absolutely just what Jesus is about to
say to the Sarah pan Asian woman but
also plenty of bread left over for the
Gentiles see where Phoenician woman
comes and says I want bread Jesus says
kids first and she says okay but they're
gonna be leftovers aren't there he says
well said madam welcome we may come back
to that that's a really interesting
passage he says well said madam you can
have some bread too and and we've been
talking about the way in which this
kingdom keeps getting bigger and bigger
lepers come in apparently unclean people
come in synagogue leaders come in
outcasts come in Demoniacs come in now
the Gentiles are coming in and and and
suddenly kingdom of God is really not
just Kingdom of Israel any longer it's
God's reign over all creation and I
think the two stories are they're partly
to tell us that and so so Sarah
Phoenician woman and piggybacking on
that that makes good sense of the purity
conversation because in there in the
purity conversation Jesus challenges
this really excluding detail of Jewish
ceremonial yeah right that the disciples
get criticized for eating when they have
exhausted sufficient right and mark in a
moment when he lets us see his audience
a little bit says this is what the Jews
do as a practice is that right and
spends a sentence and a half on that and
then Jesus says that that it's not what
goes in that corrupts it's what comes
out of a person which is a universal
truth rather than a specific religious
research and so if the syrophoenician
woman represents a coming in and a
getting bigger the vehicle by which that
can happen seems to come in in the story
of purity that Jesus is making way for
people who would formerly not have that
off the mat of to not be allowed to have
access and it's a it's a great reminder
to us because I least my history is all
Gentile as far as I can trace the family
back we were a bunch of Gentiles we're
the late comers we're the surprises
where the
under the table no question Judaism had
a way and that was Israel was set in
important ways we're the surprise and
and then I take that what I'm in more
preaching mode to say okay what
surprising people are there out there
now that we've decided or cultic lis
unclean or not quite up to our standards
are not you know not quite what we
expect of Christian people and where is
Jesus surprisingly saying to us bread
for them too yeah this is not just bread
for you
yeah so the widening isn't widening is
still going on all the time and so Paul
says to the Jew first and also to the
Greek in Romans he says to the he tries
to talk about how Gentiles are grafted
into a Jewish tree this is Mark kind of
doing this this is Mark kind of doing
that mark oh we have to the larger world
you know
yeah and and then we in our day try to
find who the larger world is yeah so do
you make any connections between the
feeding as a kind of symbolic statement
about what God does and the way in which
we deal with people in genuine need
today I mean is there is there any
combination between this and and a
hungry world there's a place in the
first feeding where it sees it says
Jesus looked on them with compassion
because he saw that they were like she
covered the the world seems to have
produced in Jesus and the needs of the
world seems to have produced in Jesus a
pang yeah a pang and this in this case
just physical needs you know not even we
don't need to go to a metaphorical or a
spiritual ization of us this is just
people are hungry and I feel bad for
them there we are that's got to reflect
that's got on our day and and the fact
of the the abundance that is shown in
both feedings from little comes much
again the fact of that abundance that
that is brought forth when compassion is
exercised has to also reflect on what is
possible in our time for people of
people of this Christ who look at a
world and feel pangs yeah there's got to
be some sense that the one who gave
abundantly then and provided abundantly
then we'll somehow equip us yeah do the
same and not let us off the hook not let
us off right yeah yeah it's it's our job
now yeah I mean it goes back to and we
keep running this thread but it goes
back to the first line the beginning of
the gospel of Jesus Christ the sunrise
so what are what are how do we continue
one reason we can get one way we
continue is to think about what does
compassion look like what does feeding
look like how does this look now and
it's our turn it's our baton yeah right
it's been passed on we reflect for a
minute or two on this thing you have
pointed out to us then that we're
beginning to in verse which is the
disciples looking more and more like
outsiders why is bark I mean this is the
Blessed st. Peter at the buzzer st.
James of buzzer st. John
Here I am they've probably gone to their
heavenly reward by now everybody around
me says we're supposed to love these
guys why does Mark tell a story about
the ones we would have thought were the
great heroes of the church and show them
being just dense time after time after
time yeah and it's gonna get worse I
mean right now it's sort of information
problems later it's gonna be nature oh
yeah discipleship problems so it's gonna
get worse when I picture myself in marks
in the living room as Mark's Gospel read
out to some people for the first time I
picture myself wanting to think that
those people are more powerful more
courageous more clever so I can be
inspired by them yeah so if I'm you know
we talked earlier in about finding
characters in the gospel with whom we
relate right how where do we find out I
think everybody in the room at some
level is going to find the disciples and
say I'm looking at them my paint on them
and I'm gonna find a clue for my life
and the strategy of undermining that or
undermining the disciples in this story
is a striking yeah just a striking
phenomenon in light of that Mark had to
know that his people would be looking
sure right so so how is he and I think
we're gonna get more about this as as
the gospel goes on but how is he using
that strategically as a part of his way
of bringing this gossip
yeah namely these are clay footed people
right value has that is a question we're
gonna have to get back to later in the
book I think but right now it's just
presented as a question it's kind of
astonishing yeah the the kind of
somewhat flat-footed explanation is Mark
just didn't like those people right
right that he lives in a time where they
were annoying to him he wants to be a
different kind of church he thinks
there's all too much stress on the
original circle the apostles and he's
just gonna show how wrong they were
about everything I suspect there's
something more subtle going on than that
I do too and I think it has again to do
with this being the beginning of the
gospel yeah this cries that we were and
then the question becomes with whom do
we identify and maybe it'll turn out to
be not so much the famous ones as the
lesser-known one was the gyrus gyrus
daughter yeah the woman who reaches out
the person who cries helped me Jesus and
not hello Here I am the Blessed Saint
Peter I'm on a roll yeah you know there
is there is in this Marianne Tolbert's
book traces out and finds people who for
one episode hold faith yeah and says
these are good soil that always rub me a
little bit the wrong way because they
didn't have to stay around
that's drafted the Sun didn't come in
scorching and so I I wonder as we follow
disciples and see them trailing off and
running away and being lacking courage
down the line
I wonder what what we're supposed to see
as the remedy for that yeah we do
because the individual I think we can
all think that if we if we had somebody
and ask him to come heal our dying
daughter and he came and healed our
dying daughter we could probably be
faithful for a minute yeah what happens
when the longitude gets carried in
here's an important question in this
book and will will be able to come back
to that later down the road
I hope there's hope I hope we find some
places where we can sink our seed into
the soil I think we're okay yeah yeah
because if it's just like us that's not
great news if the if the last word is
Peter and Andrew and James and John and
the guys end up just like us right
forever just like that but we're yeah
why are we reading this book and why is
it called the gospel yeah why is it good
news thank you